la gauche compte bien reprendre le
canton de montigny le bretonneux
remportées par la droite et le centre
lors des dernières élections
départementales en 2015 pour ce faire
une unique candidature de cette
sensibilité et en lice la gauche unie et
citoyenne pour montigny guyancourt et
les portés par le maire de guyancourt
françois morton est clair l'avenant
président des mots qui compte cinq élus
d'opposition au conseil municipal de
montigny le bretonneux et des valeurs de
gauche en commun même si aucun état
filière imparti clair si guillaume et
moi même ne nous sommes adhérents
d'aucun parti politique ça a pu nous
arriver dans notre parcours peut-être
que ça arrivera par la suite dans ce
parcours on n'en sait rien en tout cas
pour l'instant ce n'est pas le cas ça ne
veut pas dire que nous rejetons les
organisations politiques bien évidemment
on est dans une configuration assez
inédite je pense par rapport à ce qui se
passe partout ailleurs où dans notre
canton c'est la gauche qui est unie face
à trois candidatures de droite d'extrême
droite
et ça c'est une vraie fierté et c'est
aussi si on a tant travaillé pour en
arriver là c'est aussi parce que on
pense qu'il ya une réelle opportunité de
pouvoir remporter ce canton de pouvoir
accéder à des postes au conseil
départemental parler des engagements des
deux candidats la santé les solidarités
avec le redéploiement des centres de
protection maternelle et infantile les
collèges en redéfinissant le
fonctionnement actuel de la restauration
scolaire et en privilégiant les circuits
courts
enfin le logement et les mobilités
favoriser la mixité sociale ou encore
améliorer le réseau cyclable et des
propositions animé par une seule
conviction l'écologie l'écologie c'est
pas juste afin manger bio et faire du
vélo pour aller au marché non il faut
vraiment l'envisager globalement et ça
s'intègre complètement aussi avec la
solidarité avec soutenir les familles
les prix les plus précaires et redonner
du pouvoir d'achat aux gens par ce genre
de moyens mais nous allons faire en
sorte d'être entendu par rapport à ces
priorités trop je je veux je souhaite
nous souhaitons tous que le département
des yvelines
ce que ressentent réellement je vais lui
martelé durant la campagne que vous
l'avez vous allez
l'entente où un certain nombre de fois
dans nos bouches se recentre sur ses
actions de solidarité face à claire
l'avenant et françois morton trois
autres binômes celui de la majorité
sortante ensemble pour les yvelines de
la république en marché du rassemblement
national scrutin au programme les 20 et
27 juin prochains